evalúe 0 y 7 cuando es igual a menos 3
cuando es igual a cero y cuando es igual
a 7 tenemos la primera situación en la
que yo
es igual a menos 3
por lo que la expresión de 0 0 más ya
que en este caso es
- 3
- 7
el 0 más o menos algo no le va a cambiar
el valor así que vamos a ignorar este 0
y a trabajar con los demás números
esto va a ser igual a menos 3
podemos imaginar que el -3 ya se
encuentra tres lugares por debajo del
cero y con el menos siete nos iríamos
siete lugares más abajo aún del cero por
lo que nos quedaría menos 10 como
resultado pero vamos a dibujar una recta
numérica para comprender esto
visualmente voy a tratar de dibujar mi
recta numérica lo más recta que se pueda
con sus flechas y aquí voy a colocar el
cero
y aquí voy a indicar que está mi - 3 que
es con el valor que comenzamos que es el
que se encuentra aquí aquí está el 3 y a
partir de aquí vamos a restar 7 lugares
o vamos a agregar otros 7 lugares pero
hacia la izquierda vamos a movernos de
aquí hacia acá
esta flecha o este vector va a tener una
longitud de 7 de 7 lugares hacia la
izquierda así que como va la izquierda
sería menos 7 y cuál es el valor
absoluto de menos 7 pues este valor
absoluto de menos 7 va a ser igual a 7 y
cuál es la longitud de esta línea que va
a la izquierda que va del 0 al menos 3
pues va a ser de menos tres el valor
absoluto de menos 3 es igual a 3 si la
longitud de la línea naranja es 3 en su
valor absoluto y la de la línea rosa es
7 sumamos 73 y nos va a quedar que toda
esta línea la suma de estas 2
estas dos de aquí hasta acá
va a ser igual a 10
pero como va hacia la izquierda va a ser
negativo
así que nuestro resultado va a ser igual
a menos 10 escribimos aquí llegamos
hasta menos 10 y el resultado de esto es
igual a menos 10 pasemos ahora a el
segundo caso cuando ya va a ser igual a
0 lo sustituimos en esta expresión 0 +
y en este caso millet
es igual a 0 0 +
pues nuestros héroes no me van a afectar
el resultado o el valor por lo que me
quedo con -7 el resultado en este caso
va a ser igual a menos 7
ahora resolvamos la última opción cuando
es igual a 7 de nuevo sustituimos en
nuestra expresión
tenemos 0 +
hay dos formas de resolverlo una es
decir que estamos agregando un -7 o si
estamos restando un número que es
equivalente a 0 + 7 menos 7 pues va a
ser igual a 0 así que nos va a quedar
que esto es igual a cero la otra manera
es dibujando una recta numérica
dibujamos nuestra recta numérica así
quizás bueno no me salió tan recta pero
es para que se den una idea ahora
nuestro cero va a estar en esta posición
y nuestro primer valor que encontramos
aquí es un 7 por lo que voy a dibujar
aquí el número 7 entonces aquí en este
punto nos indica que tenemos del 0 al 7
estos lugares o estos números
y lo que sigue es el -7 lo que nos va a
indicar es que a partir de este punto
del 7 donde estamos vamos a recorrer 7
lugares pero hacia la izquierda aquí
comenzamos de acá y nos vamos a mover 7
lugares hacia la izquierda partiendo de
este punto a dónde vamos a llegar pues
vamos a llegar al 0 así que aquí
confirmamos que nuestra respuesta es 0